now to the latest in the standoff
between russia and ukraine president
biden says he plans to send u.s troops
to eastern europe and nato countries in
the near future as the u.s and european
allies work to dissuade russia from
possibly invading ukraine the
announcement comes as pentagon leaders
warn that an invasion would be quote
horrific for that country's civilian
population christina rafini is at the
white house with the latest christina
good morning
good morning dana keep calm carry on and
stop saying imminent that's the message
the ukrainian leader has for western
allies even as a hundred thousand
russian troops are camped out on his
country's borders
conflict
is not inevitable
[Applause]
but given the missiles and manpower
russia has positioned around ukraine u.s
defense officials say it has the
capability to cause major damage
and you can imagine what that might look
like in dense urban areas along roads
and so on and so forth it would be
horrific
more american weapons landed in kiev
this week where the u.s has already
greenlit the departure of non-essential
staff and diplomats families our message
now for any americans in ukraine
is to strongly consider leaving in a
passionate press conference yesterday
president vladimir zelinsky said the
increasingly dire warnings from the u.s
and others aren't helping we don't need
this panic
adding that ukraine is not the titanic
and the diplomats like captains should
stick with the ship
but the state department says the
rhetoric reflects reality i've been
moving u.s troops eastern europe and the
nato countries in the near term the u.s
has 8 500 troops on standby should they
be needed by nato allies and the
administration said this week it's
having separate talks with individual
european nations in case nato can't move
fast enough
meanwhile in kiev life under threat of
russian invasion goes on do you think
it's possible that the conflict could
actually reach here
i didn't know
i didn't have any information about it
so i'm just living my best life right
now and
hoping that everything will be okay
now russia for its part has also called
the rhetoric hysterical and says it has
no plans to invade russian president
vladimir putin is currently reviewing
the us's written response to russian
demands the foreign minister said this
week that although the u.s didn't
address russia's main concerns he did
see places small places in the document
where the two countries might be able to
agree jeff
christina thank you very much